Morality tends to get lost very quickly when
you start working at the SCP Foundation.
During the whirlwind of basic training, site
orientation, and learning the difference between
Euclid, Keter and Thaumiel object classes,
you have to make peace with the fact that,
as a new member of Foundation staff, you’ll
probably end up having to turn a blind eye
to doing some morally compromising things.
Then again, it’s such a normal, everyday
occurrence at the Foundation that almost everyone
working for them is desensitized to whatever
ethically dubious or downright violent tasks
they have to partake in.
And, at the end of the day, everyone knows
that it’s all for the greater good, to keep
anomalies securely in containment for the
benefit and protection of humanity.
But the one part of Foundation life that Simon
Bennet just couldn’t reason with, was the
way the very existence of D Class personnel.
Now, anyone with previous knowledge of the
SCP Foundation’s dubious practices will,
of course, be aware of D Class.
But to Simon – who had just been recruited
as a member of site security personnel – the
whole concept was not only alien, but completely
abhorrent.
D Class personnel, as he’d come to learn,
were completely expendable.
Their ranks were filled with convicted felons,
almost all of them guilty of violent crimes.
The Foundation seemed to have a habit of plucking
inmates from the highest security prisons
and penitentiaries in the world, covering
their tracks by staging the deaths of these
unwilling recruits into D Class.
From there, these criminals were essentially
used as little more than human lab rats.
And it was this part that really didn’t
sit well with Simon.
The very idea left him torn.
On the one hand, D Class were arguably the
worst of the worst; most, if not all, of them
were guilty of horrific and brutal crimes,
some that could never been forgiven by anyone.
But on the other, Simon struggled to rationalize
taking these prisoners from their incarceration,
only to subject them to anomalous creatures
and entities.
Most SCPs could do things to a D Class that
were almost as bad as what these convicts
had done to their victims, and some could
dole out far, far worse fates.
Did their actions make their cruel fates justifiable?
Did D Class personnel deserve that amount
of punishment for their crimes?
Simon didn’t know, it was a perplexing moral
conundrum.
Most days at the Foundation, those questions
echoed around his head.
He was probably better suited to a role in
the ethics committee than rank and file security.
He was uncertain if it was better to leave
a violent murderer to serve their sentence
in prison until their eventual execution,
or to abduct them and use them as a D Class
guinea pig.
It wasn’t long before his fellow security
officers tried to dissuade Simon from questioning
the Foundation’s methods, reminding him
how lucky he was to be selected to join them,
and how an easy application of amnestics could
take that all away, leaving him not only jobless
but his memory wiped as well.
Ultimately, as weeks turned into months that
then became years in the blink of an eye,
Security Officer Bennet’s moral compass
was ground down.
He started getting used to the idea of the
Foundation’s way of doing things, asking
fewer and fewer questions to oppose how morally
and ethically ambiguous a lot of their experiments
and procedures were.
Obedience to orders slowly became apathy,
and the Simon that had once been concerned
with the ethics of D Class experimentation
soon began looking at them as expendable assets,
just like the rest of the SCP Foundation did.
He even started to resent a few of them that
seemed to have it easy, on the few occasions
a member of D Class personnel got to interact
with the friendly kind of anomaly.
It didn’t seem fair, Simon thought, that
while he and the other security personnel
had to put their lives on the line whenever
a dangerous SCP breached containment.
Meanwhile, a D Class – who might have been
a multiple murderer or domestic terrorist
– got to sit in a testing chamber with a
friendly entity like SCP-999: the Tickle Monster.
Keeping up to date with the Special Containment
Procedures for the various anomalous objects
and beings held at the Foundation was an essential
part of a security officer’s job.
Ongoing testing and new discoveries that were
about an entity often led to them needing
new, updated measures to keep them securely
contained.
But it was during a routine check of these
procedures that Simon came across something…
strange.
Well, maybe not so strange when you work at
the SCP Foundation, but definitely a noticeable
level of strangeness.
Reading through the Containment Procedures
for one of the anomalies housed at the site,
Simon found a list of instructions, fairly
standard stuff for the Foundation.
The strange part was that he was sure that
he had never read this list before.
But at the same time, it wasn’t a new update
recently added to an entry in the SCP Archive.
It was paradoxically brand new information,
a detailed description of containment measures
yet also, seemingly, something that had been
written and archived ages ago.
Reading through the instructions, they described
a process that was essential to keeping one
of the site’s anomalies secure.
It had even been given its own name, the Special
Containment Procedures referring to the whole
practice as a ‘Monthly Termination’.
The more that Simon read, his eyes would widen
further, as he learned exactly what steps
this process entailed.
In his earlier days he would’ve thought
of this so-called Monthly Termination as excessive,
a needlessly cruel act even by the standards
of the SCP Foundation.
But that was the old Simon, a man who hadn’t
yet become jaded by his work, before he had
come to adopt the same apathy and disregard
for life as his fellow Foundation personnel.
Reaching the end of the passage describing
Monthly Termination, Simon alerted the other
security officers, making sure they read the
procedure too.
Some unknown feeling stirred deep within Simon,
telling him this needed to be carried out,
and it had to happen right now.
Before long, more members of staff had been
told to read the entry on Monthly Termination,
each one passing it on to their colleagues.
Then, Simon and a large detachment of other
guards began marching towards the cell blocks
where D Class personnel were imprisoned.
Almost a third of the site’s incarcerated
inmates were rounded up.
It couldn’t have been any more than a few
hundred.
Simon wasn’t sure, he couldn’t see all
of them from where he was standing.
But mostly, he didn’t care.
All he could focus on was following the Monthly
Termination procedure to the letter.
Together, he and the security detachment escorted
the collected D Class personnel through the
facility, single-file, all marching in efficient
and perfectly synchronized motion.
It was almost like a choreographed military
display.
If he hadn’t been so preoccupied with thinking
only of the procedure, Simon might have realized
how strange all this was.
All the personnel were moving at once, in
such flawless timing.
Even though this hadn’t been planned in
advance.
In fact, he and the other personnel had only
just learned about Monthly Termination.
And yet, they were carrying it out as if they
had done it a thousand times before.
The security officers continued ferrying the
D Classes through the facility, eventually
leading the convicted felons to the main entrance.
The doors were opened without question, nobody
who had read the Monthly Termination instructions
saw what was going on as anything out of the
ordinary.
A long, winding row of inmates in Foundation-issue
orange jumpsuits was then guided out of the
site’s main doors, instructed by the security
to keep walking even further.
None of them knew how far they’d really
walked.
A lot of the D Class personnel complained
and moaned, but the few that tried to leave
the single-file line were quickly put back
in place by the security detachment.
Most of them were directly verbally aggressive,
cursing and threatening the security officers.
But they still seemed compliant, walking the
way they were told to.
It was as if they had to obey, almost like
their legs wouldn’t let them resist.
One begged to be let go, turning to Simon
and pleading not to be taken wherever it was
they were going.
“I’m sorry,” Simon replied plainly,
with barely any emotion behind his words.
It was a lie; he didn’t feel sorry.
In fact, he hadn’t even been sure why he
apologized at all.
The reply had happened almost unnaturally,
like something else was speaking through him.
He wasn’t even sure how far away they’d
gotten from the facility.
It might have felt like miles if he had been
thinking about it.
But he wasn’t, none of the officers were.
They were following their instructions, totally
unaware that they’d been walking for so
long that they were starting to get blisters.
They all somehow knew they had gotten far
enough.
Beyond the reach and sight of the Foundation
facility they’d started in.
So far, in fact, that the surveillance systems
wouldn’t be able to see them.
Still moving with the same, completely synchronous
timing, Simon and the other security officers
herded the D Class personnel towards a wooded
clearing.
They formed a ring around the inmates, before
pushing them down onto their knees.
A few of them hung their heads, some even
shedding a tear.
They had already figured out what was about
to happen.
Those that hadn’t quickly caught up when
they saw the security officers covering or
deactivating their head cameras… then reaching
for their sidearms.
When they returned to the facility, Simon
and the other officers would all give the
same story.
They collectively led a third of the site’s
D Class to an area out of surveillance range,
and executed them all with their handguns.
At least, that’s how they all remembered
the incident.
But what they thought, they’d done didn’t
quite match what had actually happened.
Naturally, the Foundation higher-ups quickly
got wind of what had happened, and of such
a massive expenditure of their expendable
D Class resources.
The incident forced the SCP Foundation to
launch a full-blown investigation into the
actions of Simon, the other security officers,
and additional personnel on-site.
They quickly recognized the pattern of behavior;
they had seen it before.
They already knew not one of the guards had
actually fired their weapons.
In fact, none of them had been acting of their
own free will.
Simon and the others had no idea that the
Monthly Termination procedure didn’t exist
in the Foundation’s records, and was actually
the symptom of an SCP-2193 event.
All those D Class that had been rounded up
and marched out into the middle of nowhere
were still gone, though; not shot point-blank
like the officers thought, but the prisoners
were still no longer alive either.
Although he’d never remember it, when Simon
had been stood amongst his fellow officers,
one of the D Class had begun floating upwards.
Lifted off the ground by some invisible force,
the convicted felon drifted about three meters
in the air.
Without warning, the prisoner was then launched
up, practically fired towards the sky like
a rocket, traveling into the upper atmosphere
at several times the speed of sound.
One by one, the members of D Class all began
experiencing the same thing, floating off
the ground only to be catapulted up to the
stratosphere with such speed and force that
they vanished from view in seconds.
Meanwhile, all Simon and the other security
officers did was stand by and watch, keeping
their head cams covered or switched off.
The last of the D Class prisoners stood in
the clearing, the one that had asked Simon
to be set free.
He was still asking, begging to be helped
down as his feet were hoisted up against his
will, practically screaming for someone, anyone,
to do something.
His eyes locked with Simon’s for a split
second, before he too was sent hurtling into
the sky.
Moving that high and that fast isn’t something
a human being is at all likely to survive.
Now rid of the D Class that they had led to
their deaths, all the gathered security personnel
looked up.
It was night, starlight cast across an inky
canvas of dark sky.
But Simon was fixated on the moon, they all
were.
None of them could take their eyes off it
as it slowly appeared to blink, like a watchful
eye hanging in space above them.
Not one of them would remember what they had
seen, or what they had truly done.
No member of D Class was a saint, it’s true.
They were murderers, criminals, and dangerous
individuals.
Maybe some of them were so bad that they did
deserve to be used as test subjects, to die
at the hands of anomalous entities.
But then again, does anyone really deserve
to go out like that?
Little is known about the point of origin
of SCP-2193.
While it affects the documents stored within
the Foundation’s database, it does not function
like a computer virus or artificial intelligence.
Instead, SCP-2193-1 is an anomalous piece
of information, or an ‘infohazard’ as
SCPs like this are known.
It has been known to infect digital files,
specifically the Special Containment Procedures
for various entities, objects, and creatures
that the Foundation has recorded in its archives.
Even their most talented computer engineers
and anomalous researchers cannot determine
how this infohazard is able to accomplish
this.
It seems to infect files at random, without
any regular pattern in its timing or the type
of SCP files it appears in.
Upon infection, a file now containing SCP-2193-1
will include references to a Monthly Termination
of D Class personnel, marking it as an essential
process for keeping an anomaly secure.
Anyone that reads this suffers from what is
known as a memetic effect; essentially, they
will believe what they have read and believe
that they have always been aware of this information.
On top of that, a person infected by SCP-2193-1
will accept it as true that the Monthly Termination
is a legitimate and accepted practice within
the SCP Foundation.
They can’t be convinced that killing hundreds
of D Class personnel is anything less than
justified.
Now, you might be forgiven for thinking that
uninfected personnel can easily explain to
those who have been affected by SCP-2193-1
that the Monthly Termination isn’t an official
Foundation policy.
But this infohazard has proven itself to be
particularly infectious when spreading its
memetic influence.
Any member of Foundation personnel not yet
exposed to SCP-2193-1 can be easily convinced
that the Monthly Termination is both morally
acceptable and a Foundation-held procedure
that is absolutely necessary for anomaly containment.
If anyone that had read – and therefore
believes – the Monthly Termination process,
then they will display a lack of cognitive
dissonance whenever somebody attempts to present
them with information that conflicts with
SCP-2193-1.
While no document within their internal database
has a record of the Monthly Termination procedure,
back in January of 1999, the Foundation was
able to witness the process secondhand via
one of its agents.
During an SCP-2193 event, Agent Ysson’s
head camera was left uncovered, recording
excerpts of the precise and perfectly choreographed
execution of numerous D Class personnel.
Much like the event Simon was a part of, an
unknown anomaly caused the Earth’s moon
to appear to blink.
It is believed, by some within the Foundation,
that this is the result of a form of eldritch
entity, a being that demands a substantial
human sacrifice every month.
This being, as of yet, remains unidentified.
Just as unclear is this anomaly’s intentions,
motives, or how it is able to affect – or
perhaps use – the moon.
Of course, the SCP Foundation has its own
personnel stationed up there.
However, during recorded instances of SCP-2193
events, their agents at Luna Area 32 have
reported no unusual activity or abnormalities
at the corresponding times.
The running theory among some personnel is
that the moon isn’t this unidentified being’s
actual eye, but some kind of ocular device
like a spyglass that allows it to observe
the Monthly Termination.
Whatever this being is, it apparently possesses
an immense level of power.
How exactly it is able to create SCP-2193-1
and infiltrate the Foundation’s internal
database with that infohazard is still unknown.
As is the exact reason why it goes to such
trouble, such incalculable lengths, seemingly
just for the purpose of killing so many D
Class inmates.
The immediate assumption – albeit admittedly
a morbid and cynical one – held by most
Founation researchers studying SCP-2193 is
that this entity needs this almost ritualistic
monthly sacrifice in order to sustain itself.
One idea suggests it could be a creature that
opposes how the Foundation uses its D Class
personnel.
Maybe it, just like Simon used to, questions
the morality of convicts being used as expendable
guinea pigs.
And as such, it uses its eldritch levels of
power to remove them from the Foundation’s
reach for good.
Or perhaps, despite its subterfuge, this being
feeds on those who have wronged others, making
D Class personnel prime candidates.
That would certainly explain why the Monthly
Termination procedure causes security officers
to only bring the Foundation’s force of
expendable convicts.
And after all, there are benevolent SCPs out
there, even friendly ones, so it stands to
reason that this being could be trying to
rid the world of people who are bad enough
to be put into D Class.
But then again, this world is rarely so kind.
SCP-2193-1 makes Foundation officers bring
D Classes out to where they can’t be seen,
causes them to cover their head cameras and
believe a phony story about execution by sidearm
so nobody knows what really happens to them.
It even hides the infoharzard detailing the
Monthly Termination process at random, moving
it around to a new file whenever it's detected.
Such great effort is taken by this entity
to cover its tracks, which would suggest a
far more nefarious goal.
It’s entirely possible that this being does
all this simply to amuse itself, expending
countless lives and Foundation resources purely
for a sick, sadistic form of entertainment.
With no way of knowing the entity’s true
intention, the SCP Foundation can only sit
and vigilantly wait, an artificial intelligence
surveying their database for the next instance
of SCP-2193.
Now go check out “SCP-055 ANTI-MEME/UNKNOWN”
and “SCP-1025 ENCYCLOPEDIA OF COMMON DISEASES”
for more insights into infohazards, scare-inducing
secrets, and truths too terrifying to tell…
but only if you’re brave enough!